this is most difficult part to the how
to slice sushi it's meat stuff education
with rice other science novice on Arthur
science odd because I use mostly the
white plague because like of the campus
it's a fight the pink and the shrimps
and the onions in the greens even the
color happening the balance I don't like
to too tight for their lives because
rice you can see the light yeah to do it
to the light so means between the lights
out of the air put one sorry
because wasabi killed of the few
bacteria right not to type turn this
room so means still when you put to the
mouse enough one bites its lies if we
make the too tight it means in a very
difficult dish is that how we should eat
sushi one by one by one one things one
by one like this one of the
misconceptions that we have in the West
mostly important to the how to make
sushi it's a fresh product it's a
balance for the sushi lies halves of the
bidding of the sugar the salt it'll
taste balance then homogenized how much
wasabi how much put the soy sauce you
know it's all the details each process
have to be the balance looks easy but so
she is very deep if we use it a
chopstick turn the half way take like
this soy sauce put psi
then one by
you